remember I wrote on the first um Borat
movie at the very beginning of it when
Tom Phillips's director and then they
changed directors and I had to go back
to King of Queens but we were in The
Writer's room one day and one of his
writers this guy ant the British guy
yeah and we were I was there when I came
up with when Borah is talking about how
his wife is getting older and he
described her vagine is like the sleeve
of a wizard and it's like the whole room
like we wanted to like get up and carry
him around the room we were so happy
like we knew oh my God not only did he
just think up that I got to be here and
witness that fall out of somebody's
skull yeah I loved that I mean that was
my first love when I started doing
stand-up is even before going on stage
sitting around with comedians yeah and
watching them bounce ideas off each
other yeah there's nothing like that I
know I'm Upstream where it's being
created I'm not getting it I'm not
working in office and getting it when
it's finally broadcast yeah I'm watching
it get foreign